politique encore avec la surprise du
jour le député socialiste de côte-d'or
laurent grandguillaume annonce qu'il ne
se représentera pas aux élections
législatives de 2010 est bon ce soir
laurent grandguillaume enfants annonces
faites sur votre blog vous avez
également envoyer votre démission
aujourd'hui du conseil municipal de
dijon le tout elle dit vous pour
respecter le principe de non cumul dans
le temps explique et nous vous êtes
comme emmanuel macron vous trouvé qu'en
france une fois les choses qu'à moitié
où vous trouvez que les élus ne sont pas
entendues vous avez des ambitions
présidentielles c'est à la mode alors je
n'ai pas d'ambition présidence et je
vous rassure en tout cas j'ai toujours
considéré que la politique ne devait pas
être un métier mecs un engagement qu'il
est limitée dans le temps je m'étais
appliquer le non-cumul des mandats en
2012 après mon élection en tant que
député puisque j'avais démissionné de mi
mandat d'adjoint au maire de bize prise
en agglomération et de conseil général
faisait déjà beaucoup trop et comme j'ai
dit récemment je défends si le non cumul
des mandats dans le temps est reconduite
dans le temps en fait les mandats à une
durée oui mais vous quitter l'assemblée
nationale après un mandat seulement on
va dire qu'il ya dans le temps ça fait
dix ans que je suis élu c'est le belge
et comme j'ai été élu justement en
premier conseil municipal en 2008 et
donc le temps passe et je les fais de
manière intense engagé passionné mais
maintenant j'ai envie de retourner aussi
à la vie professionnelle de porter
d'autres projets associatifs et plein
d'autres choses que je n'ai pas eu
encore le temps de faire vous avez pris
la 1re circonscription à la droite vous
pouviez espérait elle a conservé à
gauche françois rebsamen a dit infos
dijon on va soutenir laurent de toutes
nos forces ça veut dire que vous ne
l'avez pas prévenu lui non plus écoutez
moi j'ai pris ma décision j'avais laissé
entendre cela déjà il ya plusieurs mois
que je réfléchissais à ce que j'allais
faire demain il y a plein de jeunes
talents dans cette circonscription et
puis en plus il ya une majorité de
conseillers départementaux de gauche
dans cette circonscription ce qui
n'était pas le cas en 2012 la gauche a
progressé qu'elle est en capacité de
gagner cette circonscription et puis
personne n'est irremplaçable vous savez
je crois que justement ce qu'il faut
c'est retrouver les têtes c'est pas
parce qu'on est jeune qu'on doit faire
comme les anciens et puis rester ad
vitam aeternam en poste il est temps de
changer aussi justement la politique il
est grand temps je crois laurie les
citoyens le dise il ya tellement de
défiance justement à ce propos laurent
grandguillaume est un grand et un bon
parlementaire vous savez qu'il dit ça
aujourd'hui en réaction c'est françois
sauvadet lui des idées je conseil
départemental alors c'est vrai que vous
faites assez consensus votre sérieux
votre honnêteté est ce que finalement à
un moment où il ya vraiment de la
défiance dans le pays eh ben les gens
n'ont pas besoin de deux députés comme
vous qui font consensus pour leur nette
mais leur travail est ce qu'on doit
faire de la politique uniquement à
travers des mandats je ne le crois pas
je pense que l'on peut faire de la
politique dans la vie de la cité à
travers des associations à travers des
engagements citoyens c'est ce que je
vais faire
je vais bien sûr avoir des occupations
au nom de l'intérêt général je vais
d'abord terminer mon travail de député
jusqu'en juin 2017 avec différents
dossiers que j'ai traité et puis elle en
même temps bien sûr préparer la
transition mais vous quittez le conseil
municipal de dijon maintenant vous ne
pensez pas de vos électeurs pas vous
reprocher de quitter le navire en cours
de montage du tout parce qu'en fait j'ai
plutôt des messages sympathiques et puis
vous savez je vais suivre une formation
en même temps comment la parlementaire
pour jean veut préparer à ma transition
professionnelle et moi je ne sais pas
faire plusieurs choses à la fois je ne
sais pas être partout en même temps je
vois comment font les autres et donc je
préfère que quelqu'un qui ait le temps
justement et bien me remplace au conseil
municipal pour être disponible pour les
citoyens c'est aussi cela je crois à
l'exigence de responsabilité nous rester
au ps bien sûr je reste au ps à ma
famille politique je suis socialiste
j'ai jamais me montra pendant la poche
je suis de gauche et ça n'empêche pas de
respecter aussi celles et ceux qui ont
des idées différentes
mais bien sûr je reste au parti séisme
des départs aux politiques avec des
retours on en a connu c'est un départ
vraiment définitif écoutez dans la vie
y'a rien de définitif je veux dire moi
je suis aujourd'hui j'ai fait un choix
je vais retourner à la vie
professionnelle et puis m'engager dans
la vie professionnelle et puis on verra
bien de quoi l'avenir sera fait et
quelques choix je le fais dans le futur
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est pas un
plan de carrière où je ne sais quoi
voilà je fais ce choix en toute
sincérité et puis en 10 secondes ce sera
à dijon et dans quels domaines alors je
serai à dire mais je ne sais pas encore
le domaine sera là forcément la
formation puisque j'étais conseillère en
formation en formation ressources
humaines management donc jeu sur une
formation dans ce domaine
on verra pour la suite merci laurent
grandguillaume